he's the popular Steve Levy covering his
25th Stanley Cup final for the
mothership is the Blues won Game five
not without a little controversy and
Steve joins us now leaves good morning
how are you yeah
good morning pepper pig is where I'm at
with my young kids so I'm talking pepper
that's my first time okay thank you
Steve that's all we wanted from you have
a good flight good talking to you well
okay there was controversy here how big
a controversy was last night that finish
I'll tell you about two texts I got one
from a st. Louis fan who recalled the
Don denken jerk all that worked against
the Cardinals wow so that's for the
older generation and then herzman NFL
assistant type was that the the missed
call last night was as bad if not worse
than a missed pass interference in Rams
Saints last year at the NFC Championship
game so yeah so those are some of the
comparisons from the younger people to
the older people this is a big deal Dan
and I'll tell you know you you know want
to get too deep into the officiating
because not sure how many people are
actually interested in the NHL as as a
depth issue add at the official every
referee spot and they've kind of done it
to themselves because of some awful
mistakes and earlier rounds they have
put great referees on the bench
so they've ice these guys and they so
their way down their depth chart by the
time they get to the Stanley Cup final
and so you're seeing referees in the
Stanley Cup final otherwise would not be
calling these games and that is
definitely a factor in what happened
last night
okay walk us through the play yeah so
it's it's Tyler Bozak and NOLA Chari of
the Bruins and the Chari has the puck
and the pucks in his skates and Bozak is
going for it and just you know it's a
trip or it's a slewfoot or it's
somewhere in between and you can even
see that beause after the Blues as his
palms in the air already ready to arch
be the call of the official and the
official doesn't even make the call it
was and all the Bruins then stop playing
because it looks so egregious that it
had to be a penalty called and the Sur
play was allowed to continue on so it's
sort of twofold there's no call you got
the one guy already complaining to the
rest about being sent to the box which
isn't even happening
and then you have the Bruins sort of
standing around and watching what's
going on and that allows David Perron to
really beat three Boston players and
score the goal which is you know
eventually the game-winning goal so look
it's a bad looking Dan this this cup has
been really good this has been a really
special Stanley Cup based a lot on the
teams and the market right st. Louis has
been waiting for this for so long this
has been a heavy heavy hard-hitting
series and unfortunately you get it you
get a call like last night you know
that's what people are talking about
that the front page of the st. Louis
post-dispatch this morning blares you
know what a trip we do love like clever
newspaper headlines but also I I think
the Blues prepared for a penalty leaves
I think they are right so I can't sit
here and go boy what are the Bruins
complaining about a penalty should have
been called and I think the Blues
expected a penalty to be called no
question and and and they you know they
had their palms near also to the player
Bozak of st. Louis I think was you know
on his way to head to the penalty places
and you know so he's not continuing on
either good David Ferran to keep playing
and score that goal so a lot of you know
we're going to talk about the call I get
it Boston was dominant in the first
period this game should have been over
in the first period
I think they out shot him you know I
shall see those 18 to 7 so there's a lot
going on and let's we're not that far
removed from from Game three when when
Boston wins in same was 7 to 2
Craig Berube be still interim at go to
the Blues goes on the attack the next
day then and he goes three separate
times in an eight-minute span he goes
eight in the first three rounds we at
least penalized team in the NHL and you
know you kept banging home that point
you know and you wonder if it's you know
the Blues discipline or actually the way
it's being called in games four and five
but the Bruins power play opportunities
have been cut in half so you know do we
think st. Louis you know smart and up
all of a sudden or did he really have an
impact on how the officials are calmer
series so and that makes for obviously a
fabulous fabulous Peter come Sunday
night in st. Louis to see how that's
called he's Steve Levy from the
mothership covering the Stanley Cup
final when Charles out
like when I realized he had a broken jaw
and then I saw that they were fitting
him with a special globe helmet then I
said you know what he'll play like
hockey players play but should we be
surprised that he played with a broken
jaw no we shouldn't be especially
because it's him right hockey players
you know are a different breed they're
the bravest athletes on the planet I
think and and while hockey has gotten a
little soft you don't gotten away from
the fighting and all of that they are
still the bravest and you put Chara on
top of that list I think it was Mel into
fighting Steve if I said let's take a
poll
no names attached what would players
want fighting back in hockey absolutely
dead no doubt in my mind I would say if
you ran a poll 75% of the players would
vote for fighting in well and and play
75% of the media the other thing I was
curious about this with netting and a
hockey game how many arenas have
protective netting so when pucks fly
into the stands nobody gets hurt they're
only in the end zones okay behind the
goal which makes a lot of sense the NHL
has come a long way on this they used to
have really short glass around the side
so that glass has gotten much higher
over the years but the netting is only
around the end zone quite frankly Dan
you know you see it once you walk in the
building but after you're staring
through it for five minutes you don't
even notice it's there and it's the it's
the way to go man and baseball I think
has to follow that as well yeah that's
what I telling people and I went to a
hockey game and I saw the netting and
then after a while I didn't even I'm you
watch the game and that's why when I
look at baseball and go if you put it in
it will become the new normal and people
won't be upset I totally agree and look
in nowadays you look around on a crowd
especially those great expensive seats
people are on their phone the whole good
no just not they're not paying attention
and so that's just you're protecting
them from protecting themselves you know
they're just not paying attention and in
the NHL you know
I hope they don't go they really hasn't
been an issue along the side you know
behind the benches where there is
nothing it's just a little higher glass
but that's probably inevitable too you
know it's probably inevitable too and
here's a chance to get out in front of
it and look smart and really nobody gets
hurt because as you say you know five
minutes into watching the event it
disappears through realize how many
sports centers have you done
apparently not 5000 because I'm waiting
for my special well it hasn't happened
yet
well I are you counting any errors no no
not rears I thought 2,000 was the magic
number that I put up i I was there 18
years how could she do twice as many as
me I mean come on maybe like a deck
maybe i counting rear no maybe really
they reared twelve times the morning
filled up till 6 p.m. no you know what
I'm coming back to do more sports
dinners how many sports
I don't we didn't do too many sports
centers together didn't we not enough
but you were always very kind so and of
course the Sports Center you missed was
my biggest down and I I tune in I think
that's when my daughter one of my
daughter's was born and I just tuned in
because I tuned in to Sports Center and
Oberman is crying and I go oh my gosh
Keith Keith he broke down he's crying on
the air and I go oh my god so I called
the assignment desk I said why is why is
Oberman crying they go you didn't see it
I go no they go no levy just said
bulging disc but he didn't say disc and
I go right Oh No
and I felt so bad because if I don't
take that night off then you're just
you're just Steve Levy I mean you're not
bulging disc leaving actually it's kind
of worked out there why don't you start
a foundation called Vincent no
coffee the next day it was great
television that was 23 years ago so
what's like Chris Webber started a
timeout foundation how about a bulging
disc people with I don't know raise your
hand if you have a bulging disc that
would work out just great I'd rather
have the be known for the hockey
overtime saying but that doesn't seem to
have the staying power as bulging yeah
nobody cares about overtime hey tell
Melrose we set a low great to catch up
with you leaves safe travels thank you
Steve leaving from the mothership for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]